es gibt jede Menge Gemüsepflanzen die
man im Februar aussähen kann welche das
sind zeige ich euch heute also macht's
euch gemütlich holt euch eure
anzuchtsschalen und dann machen wir
zusammen unsere fbrur aussarten und wir
starten mit der Aubergine da habe ich
gleich zwei Sorten die ich super gerne
anbauen möchte das ist einmal die Sorte
Lea das ist eine richtig schöne so eine
nicht so eine klassische Aubergine
sondern eine hell violette Runde
Aubergine die wächst auch richtig gut
auf dem Balkon übrigens und das hier ist
eine meiner Lieblingssorten h de
barbentan ich seähe die Auberginen hier
in größere Schächen aus da mache ich
mehrere Samen in ein Töpfchen ich werde
jetzt pro Sorte so ungefähr fünf Samen
nehmen dann später wenn die ihre ersten
Laubblätter nach den Keimblättern
entwickelt haben pickiere ich die dann
in einzelne Töpfchen aber die bekommen
dann auch gleich so große töpfcheninen
brauchen relativ viel Platz in der
Anzucht was ihr jetzt auch aussehen
könnt ist die Chili das mache ich jetzt
nicht weil ich die schon im letzten
Monat ausgesäht habe aber man kann im
Februar immer noch wunderbar Chilis
aussähen jetzt kommt eine meiner
absoluten Lieblingssorten im
Gemüsegarten das ist die Sorte Nagels
frühweiß man hört es schon am Namen das
ist eine sehr frühe weißkohlsorte wie im
letzten Video auch könnt ihr fast alle
Sorten die ich euch hier vorstelle auch
bei uns im Shop kaufen der ist leider
gerade ein bisschen abgegrast also ihr
habt nach dem letzten Video ordentlich
viel eingekauft aber wir stocken das
jetzt alles wieder auf das ist jetzt
wieder ein Kandidat den ich im letzten
Video schon ausgesäht habe das ist der
Krabi da sehe ich gerne die Sorte als zu
ist da super Schmelz ist auch eine Sorte
die ich richtig gerne aussähe mache ich
jetzt nicht noch mal genauso wie die
fysales die ist auch schon in der Erde
gelandet die Pflänzchen habe ich gerade
pickiert aber die beiden könnt ihr im
Februar auf jeden Fall auch noch
Aussehen genauso wie der Blumenkohl das
hier ist die Sorte Amabile die habe ich
im letzten Video auch schon ausgesätt
also letzten Monat also machen wir mal
weiter mit der mexikanischen Minigurke
wenn ihr das noch nie ausprobiert habt
dann macht das mal das ist eine so große
kleine gestreif Hälfte Minigurke die
baue ich am liebsten im Gewächshaus an
also da wachsen die bei mir einfach sehr
viel besser als im Freiland funktioniert
aber auch im Freiland also wenn braucht
nicht zwangsläufigigen Gewächshaus die
schmecken richtig erfrischend im Sommer
also man kann die auch einlegen so wie
saure Gurken mache ich manchmal wenn ich
ein bisschen zu viele angebaut habe
sonst kann man die einfach so wegsnacken
bei der Gartenarbeit im Hochsommer
richtig schön erfrischend als nächstes
kommt in die Erde die artichocke ich
will im neuen Garten auf jeden Fall
wieder Artischocken haben das hier ist
die Sorte Green Globe ich werde
insgesamt vier Artischocken Pflanzen
jeden Topf lege ich zwei Samen damit auf
jeden Fall in jedem Topf einer aufgeht
die bleiben dann auch in den Töpfen bis
sie dann irgendwann nach draußen
gepflanzt werden können und jetzt
natürlich noch gut angießen ich verwende
dafür diese Ballbrause weil das schön
sanfte Dusche ist für die Pflanzen und
die Samen so an Ort und Stelle bleiben
die kann man einfach im Wasser Aufladen
also viele Fragen immer wie kriegt man
denn das Wasser in die Ballbrause rein
also einfach kopfüber rein halten und
dann saugt die sich voll und
mittlerweile eins meiner liebsten
Gartenwerkzeuge ich habe gerade meine
andere anzugsschale geholt weil jetzt
nämlich Pflanzen kommen die ich direkt
hier reinshen würde das ist einmal die
Frühlingszwiebel isikona die habe ich
aber auch schon letzten Monat angebaut
ich mache weiter mit einem selleri der
heißt Mars aber es gibt auch noch eine
andere Sorte die ich richtig gerne mag
die nennt sich Monarch das ist eine
Knollensellerie Sorte und den sehe ich
immer relativ früh im Jahr aus weil der
so langsam wächst also ich finde
knollensellererie irgendwie deswegen
auch so sympathisch weil das so ein
gemächlicher genos ist und weil es ein
lichtkärmer ist feuchte ich die Erde
jetzt an bevor ich die Samen drauf
streusele weil selbst die sanfte
Ballbrause die Samen sonst ganz schön
rumschleudern würde bei lichtkeim man
streuselt man die Samen nämlich einfach
nur auf die Erde auf man kann auch so
maximal ein halben Centimeter Erde
drüber geben aber das mache ich
eigentlich nie das sind diese ganz fein
Samen hier davon streäusel ich jetzt so
möglichst nur zwei drei Stück pro
Töpfchen hier drauf aber das ist fast
undwöglich weil die so fein sind auch
ein Lichtkeimer ist das Basilikum das
habe ich euch auch im letzten Video
schon gezeigt deswegen werde ich das
diesmal auch nicht sehen wir haben in
unserem Wurzelwerks Sortiment eine
ziemlich große Auswahl an Salaten ich
habe hier einmal einen Salat der heißt
Summertime der ist für die warm Monate
geeignet den könnt ihr auch jetzt schon
aussehen ich starte aber mit zwei
anderen Sorten die eine habe ich letztes
Mal auch schon ausgeseht das ist die
Sorte meine Lieblingssorte das ist
nämlich eine richtig schön frostharte
Sorte davon habe ich aber schon eineige
Pflanzen deswegen mache ich jetzt noch
einen kleinen Abstecher zu einem grünen
Salat der heißt till den kennen bestimmt
auch viele von euch das ist ein richtig
schöner Eichblattsalat und auch Salat
ist ein Lichtkeimer deswegen wird die
Erde erstmal angefeuchtet bevor die
Samen einfach nur drauf gestreuselt
werden ich habe ganz vergessen die
Pflanzen zu beschriften also holen wir
das mal schnell nach das ist nämlich
doof wenn man das vergisst wen man
später sich dann gar nicht merken kann
welche Sorten eigentlich richtig gut
waren im Garten und welche nicht weil es
ist ja richtig schön wenn man nach und
nach lernt welche Sorten einen am besten
schmecken eine Sache die wir richtig
gerne essen ist der rucula Rucola
bedeckt man so ungefähr ein halben bis 1
cm dick mit Erde da packe ich jetzt auch
wieder einfach in die Mitte des
Töpfchens sagen wir ein zweiam
normalerweise sollt ihr alles aufgehen
wir haben ja da ein großes Augenmerk
drauf dass wir eine gute Keimfähigkeit
haben mit unserem Saatgut ich mache
übrigens jeden Monat so ein aussitv also
wenn ihr am Ball bleiben wollt und rund
ums Jahr ernten wollt aus eurem
Gemüsegarten dann folgt mir gerne damit
ihr die nächsten Videos nicht verpasst
und dann können wir immer unsere
aussaten zusammen machen als nächstes
ziehe ich Mangold vor das ist ja auch
ein richtig leckeres Gemüse was ein sehr
guter Spinatersatz ist mangold ist bei
mir auf jeden Fall sogar noch
ertragreicher als Spinat und man kann
das ja sehr ähnlich essen also wir essen
die Blätter wie Spinat und die Stängel
dann gedünstet man kann die auch richtig
toll fermentieren das schmeckt so lecker
ich fermentiere den immer in Flaschen
dann hält er sich über ein Jahr lang
also ist richtig tolle Methode um den
haltbar zu machen ist sie nicht
wunderschön auch die Zeichnung Alexandra
die unsere Zeichnung macht ist glaube
ich irgendwie eine Magierin auf jeden
Fall bin ich immer hin und weg von ihren
Zeichnungen und wir haben jetzt auch
eine zweite Zeichnerin ins Boot geholt
die hat auch schon richtig richtig tolle
Illustrationen für zukünftige
satartguttütchen gemacht die heißt
Katharina und jetzt sehee ich Spinat im
Haus aus man kann im Februar auch schon
im Gewächshaus Spinat sehen aber da
unser Garten noch im konstruktions Modus
ist mache ich das jetzt im Haus das ist
die Sorte butterflay da mache ich genau
wie beim Mangold auch einfach einzelne
Löcher wo die Samen reinommen und dann
kann ich die schon ganz bald
rauspflanzen sobald draußen alles fertig
ist vielleicht habt ihr auch noch
Wintergemüse in euren beten stehen das
erst noch aufgegessen werden muss
vielleicht der letzte Lauch und
Rosenkohl dann ist das eine gute Sache
wenn man noch keinen Platz hat draußen
dass man einfach im Haus die Pflänzchen
vorzieht bei der nächsten Pflanze ist es
mir ganz wichtig dass nur diejenigen von
euch die ein Gewächshaus haben mitmachen
es es geht nämlich um die Tomaten es
gibt ja Freilandtomaten und
gewächshaustomaten die Freilandtomaten
pflanzt man Mitte Mai nach den
Eisheiligen also erst dann wenn wirklich
keine Fröste mehr drohen weil Tomaten
eben frostempfindlich sind und die
gewächshaustomaten kann man je nachdem
wie das Wetter ist schon einen Monat
früher Pflanzen deswegen werde ich jetzt
meine Tomaten aussähen die ich ins
Gewächshaus Pflanze alle die nur
Freiland Tomaten anbauen wollen oder
auch nur mit einem Dach sozusagen
draußen die nicht so Wärme geschützt
sind warten bitte noch weil wenn man zu
früh mit der Anzucht beginnt die
Pflanzen sehr schwächlich werden also
denen tut das nicht gut solange in ihrem
kleinen Töpfchen in der anzuchtstation
zu stehen wenn sie eigentlich schon so
groß sind dass sie raus wollen deswegen
zügelt euch ich weiß Tomaten sind
großartig aber es bringt ja nichts wenn
wir unseren Pflanzen durch unsere
gartensehnsucht mehr Schaden als Nutzen
deswegen haben wir jetzt erstmal nur die
gewächshaustomaten in die Erde und in
der Realität baue ich auch viel mehr
Sorten an als ich jetzt hier aussähe
aber ich muss die Videos ja noch früher
Filmen damit Sie dann rechtzeitig Anfang
Februar für euch fertig sind das heißt
bei mir ist es jetzt noch Januar
deswegen sehe ich nur ein paar Sorten
aus das ist einmal die Tomatensorte
sirisgelb eine gelbe Tomatensorte ich
weiß gelbe Tomaten sind oft nicht so
ganz so beliebt aber es gibt ein paar
richtig tolle gelbe Sorten wir haben
natürlich auch rote Tomatensorten bei
uns im Wurzelwerk Sortimente das hier
ist die primabella an der sehe ich jetzt
auch so ungefähr fünf Samen aus ich
mache immer gar nicht so viel
Tomatensorte weil ich es liebe so eine
ganz bunte Auswahl an Tomaten zu haben
und von jeder Sorte eigentlich so
maximal drei Stück anbaue aber worauf
ich hinaus wollte ist dass ich dann
einfach noch mal ohne Kamera wirklich
Mitte Februar wenn es soweit ist meine
restlichen Tomaten fürs Gewächshaus auss
seh die primabella ist übrigens auch
eine richtig tolle Freilandsorte also da
braucht ihr kein Gewächshaus um die
anzubauen natürlich wächst sie im
gewächsaus auch richtig gut aber die ist
richtig tolerant gegen die Kraut und
braunfeule das ist ja die
tomatenkrankheit die ein früher oder
später quasi jedes Jahr einen Strich
durch die Rechnung macht gerade im
Freiland und dann ist es natürlich super
wichtig dass man Sorten anbaut die damit
klarkommen so wir haben noch eine andere
Sorte die ich euch zeigen wollte für
alle die auf dem balkongärtnern das ist
die Sorte Rotkäppchen eine kleine
buschtomate die auch super viel trägt
die muss man auch nicht ausgeizen ist
auch eine richtig tolle Empfehlung für
euch und wir gehen jetzt raus weil wir
können schon die allerersten Sorten
draußen im bet anbauen stellt euch mal
vor willkommen in meinem neuen Garten
das ist das erste Mal dass ich den auf
Youtube zeige bevor wir gleich loslegen
erzähle ich euch noch was und zwar gibt
es gerade eine Sonderaktion auf meinen
Kurs Gemüsegarten starten das ist mein
Videokurs mit dem ich ja schon ganz
viele von euch durchs Gartenjahr
begleiten durfte indem ich euch Schritt
für Schritt zeige wie man den
pflegeleichten und richtig ertragreichen
üppigen wunderschönen Gemüsegarten
anlegt und da haben wir gerade zum Start
in die Gartensaison eine Rabattaktion
also wenn ihr euch anmelden wollt dann
ist jetzt eine gute Gelegenheit dafür
ich würde mich wahnsinnig freuen wenn
ich euch durchs Gartenjahr begleiten
darf das ist ein Videokurs den könnt ihr
ganz gemütlich von zu Hause aus im
eigenen Tempo durchgehen und den Link
findet ihr im oberen angepinnten
Kommentar jetzt geht's los mit den
aussaten im Bet und ich starte mit der
dicken Bohne die kommt hier in dieses
bet ich hole mal meine pflanzleine und
dann legen wir los die Sorte die ich
anbaue heißt hangdown grünkernig und ich
spann mir jetzt hier eine Schnur damit
ich eine Gerade aussahrille hinbekomme
dicke Boden sind was was nicht viele
Leute anbauen aber völlig zu Unrecht das
ist so ein tolles Gemüse wenn ihr das
noch nie ausprobiert habt macht das auf
jeden Fall man kann die auch im Herbst
sehen und dann überwintern die im betet
und liefern Frühsommer eine erste Ernte
ab aber man kann sie eben auch jetzt im
Frühling sehen und bekommt dann einfach
nur ein paar Wochen später auch eine
Ernte von den deckenboden weil ich im
Herbst noch keinen Garten hatte mache
ich das eben jetzt immer ein schönes
Gefühl unsere wurzelwerg satgutütchen
aufzumachen ich kann es immer noch nicht
so ganz glauben dass ich einfach meine
eigene saatgutmarke rausgebracht habe
ihr seht hinten auf den Tütchen auch
immer den Abstand der ist hier 60 x 10
cm also 60 cm mache ich in der Reihe
deswegen kommen auf 12 m die meine Bee
breit sind zwei rein und alle 10 cm lege
ich eine Bohne ab und hier steht 6 cm
tief es ist meistens so je größer der
Samen und die hier sind richtig groß
desto tiefer muss man den auch einsellen
generell solltet ihr natürlich wenn ihr
jetzt Sachen draußen aussätt darauf
achten dass es noch richtig richtig kalt
werden kann also habt immer den
Wetterbericht immer Auge wenn ihr so
früh im Jahr aussaten macht das geht
auch nicht in allen Regionen in den
Alpen z.B wird jetzt wahrscheinlich noch
Schnee liegen wenn bei euch Schnee liegt
dann könnt ihr natürlich noch nichts
aussähen bei uns ist es gerade relativ
mild deswegen bin ich guter Dinge schon
loszulegen und eine Sache die super
wichtig ist wenn man so früh im Jahr
gärtnert sind winterfliese also gerade
wenn ihr kein Gewächshaus habt in dem
ihr jetzt aussid oder keinen
frühbetkasten dann könnt ihr eure
Pflanzen auch richtig gut mit einem
rostschutzfliesß für Gärtner schützen
bevor das Licht gleich komplett weg ist
machen wir jetzt mal ein bisschen
schneller zwei richtig tolle
radieschenens Sorten die gehen auch
beide jetzt schon im frühbildkasten oder
Gewächshaus da habe ich hier einmal die
Sorte Sora das ist meine Liebste Sorte
das ist die rote und die andere Sorte
sind die Eiszapfen wenn man mal was
Besonderes will die sehen wirklich aus
wie Eiszapfen und ab Anfang März können
wir dann auch Radieschen und Spinat im
Freiland aussähen dann mache ich wieder
ein neues Video zu der Aussat im März
also abonniert gerne meinen Kanal wenn
ihr das nicht verpassen wollt ich habe
euch ja eben gesagt dass ihr im Februar
auch die allerersten Tomaten aussehen
könnt aber tomatenaussah ist so ein
komplexes Thema dass ich dazu noch ein
eigenes Video gemacht habe das verlinke
ich euch hier drüben also schaut euch
das gerne an wenn ihr jetzt auch
loslegen möchtet mit den Tomaten oder
euch schon mal darauf vorbereiten wollt
im Erz loszulegen ansonsten geht raus
macht die Welt ein bisschen grüner
vergesst die Rabattaktion für den
gartenkuss nicht und dann sehen wir uns
im nächsten Video wieder Tschüss bis
dann